looking for your next RPG fix well look
no further because we've got this year's
smartest and most compelling RPG
experience right here Soul hackers too
this original Standalone tale will take
you on a heady journey through a gritty
futuristic World in which people and
demons coexist and the end of the world
is fast approaching
there's so much to love about the latest
title from Atlas the company who brought
you the Beloved Persona and shin Megami
tensei series but since we don't want to
keep you here all day let's just run
through the top three
Soul hackers 2 isn't your typical jrpg
it's not your average silly adventure
with teenagers this story focuses on
Ringo and AI given human form who's been
tasked with saving the world from its
imminent doom and to do that she'll need
to make use of the power of Soul hacking
to bring key allies back from death and
explore Japan's strange underbelly where
demons and people live alongside each
other the deeper Ringo goes into this
world and connects with her new
teammates the more complicated and
interesting it gets this is a serious
thoughtful and Powerful story about the
nature of human existence and our future
it's the kind of game that'll give you a
ton to think about even when you're not
playing it it's all too rare that RPGs
give us a woman as a lead character
which is a shame because the ones that
do tend to be pretty great but
fortunately we've got one of those dope
female protagonists right here in Soul
hackers too in this game we're
experiencing Ringo's life from the very
moment she was created and her life's
journey is definitely one worth taking
Ringo isn't just a badass she's also
usually the smartest person in the room
quick to understand and process new
information and work out new solutions
to every problem that rears its ugly
head she may have just been born
yesterday but she's no dummy this lady
comes prepared when it's time to have
existential discussions about the nature
of the soul and what happens when we die
but even though she's a genius she's
still got a lot to learn about humans
and herself this is a complicated world
full of complicated characters and Ringo
has her work cut out for her if she
wants to get to the bottom of all of
this but with her brains and a Charming
team of devil Summoners they might just
have a chance battles and soul hackers
too are all about harnessing the power
of demons against your foes in this
world devil Summoners find and enter
into contracts with demons to utilize
their abilities Persona and smt fans
will find themselves right at home
because the demons here work a lot like
the personas from those games once
you've befriended a new demon you can
develop it by using it in battle to gain
experience and new abilities or fuse it
with another demon to create a whole new
stronger demon and there's so much more
you can do with them in Japan's secret
demon filled underbelly these guys are a
spectacle all to themselves it's Soul
hackers 2 wasn't on your radar already
it should be this is a smart and
thoughtful RPG for a wider audience with
an incredible new female protagonist in
an original story that doesn't require
any ketchup and you get to play with
demons sounds to me like Soul hackers 2
is a game you're gonna need to get into
why not